[Musique]
chocolat les chassant des chats un ton
joyeux des visages souriants une
contrebasse entraînante avec rise up
praliné gay-para hélène labarrière parle
de manière facétieuse du racisme de l'
esclavage rise up si on veut le traduire
c'est soulevez vous et c'est aussi
et un mot clé de plein de mouvements de
protestation aux états unis sur plein de
pages qui sont les black light mathurin
les ferguson ne le théâtre comme tout le
spectacle vivant comme toute création
comme but ultime que les gens se posent
des questions c'est pas à nous de donner
les réponses que je suis tournoi qu'on
me voit dans la vue j'ai pas de toit et
des récits de tradition orale des
comptes afro américains et caribéens
rise up est un aboutissement de 30 ans
de travail
le jazz musiques emblématiques de la
traite négrière a aussi toute sa place
donner à entendre les mots qui sont pas
dit et puis de donner aussi une
dimension poétique qui ailleurs une
autre que la musique raconte aussi une
histoire qui n'est peut-être pas la même
paire faire entendre l'histoire ce
principal déjà c'est transmettre les
cris puisque c'est quand même ça au
départ ses comptes
donc on a oublié et puis on ajoute de ce
une dimension théâtrale mai
l'exigence c'est le conte la restitution
du corps ne faut pas que la mise en
scène mange d'histoire adultes ou
enfants les lectures sont multiples rise
up ou la démonstration que l' esclavage
appartient à notre histoire commune
[Musique]